the appearance of a Georgia detective in
a reality crime show raises questions
about her judgment in a high-profile
murder case detective sommer Benton
arrived on the scene of an apparent
self-defense shooting with cameras
rolling defendant Victoria Rickman went
on trial for murder but Benton's words
and actions on camera also faced
scrutiny in a preview of Saturday's 48
hours Erin Moriarty explores whether the
reality show had an impact on the case
September 13th 2013 I received the call
3 o'clock in the morning I was told that
we had a female who had stated she had
been raped did she had shot and killed
her rapist I of course think this is
going to probably be a self-defense case
she's got a rapist off the street all I
thought was I'll shake her hand I'm
summer our Benton and I am the lead
homicide detective the Victoria Rickman
case in her 16 years on the job
detective Benton has been the lead
detective on 65 homicide cases but it
was the shooting death of will Carter
jr. in the early morning hours of
September 13 2013 that put the detective
in the spotlight
this isn't adding up as Benton
investigated video cameras from a
reality show titled inside homicide were
rolling the TV crews were embedded with
the Atlanta Police Department and we're
following the action the night the
Victoria shot her on-again off-again
boyfriend and how would you describe
this show just filled with lies 41:30
show me 26 on Clifton there were so many
things that were completely false for
some reason this girl she did a tactical
reload the fact that she reloaded the
gun that wasn't true if you guys can get
me every rape case she has ever filed
the fact that she had
you know that she had been raped by so
many men so many times it's too big to
email that wasn't true it looks like she
was training to kill Wow please give me
a break
it just came across as what's gonna make
a good TV episode my name is Amanda
Clarke Palmer I represent Victoria
Rickman you knew this was gonna happen
we're dealing with an investigation that
Wow was done quickly wasn't done
thoroughly
she has no scratches no bruising it
certainly seems and looks like the TV
cameras affected did it ever occur to
you that you might be putting wrong
information and affecting potential
jurors who see this show no if she had
been raped that night then this would
have been a justified shooting and I
would have written it up as one but this
was not a justified shooting this was
cold-blooded murder and Erin Moriarty is
here with us now this is just stunning
to hear that you're seeing a blend of
fact and fiction how did this impact
this case a trial
well the prosecution would say it didn't
because of course during voir dire they
asked all the jurors and all the jurors
say they didn't see it but the bottom
line is especially in this day and age
it's online and I have to be honest I
saw it when I first started reporting on
this it does color your judgment you
have a woman who says she's shot in
self-defense but then you have a police
officer very credible police officer who
is actually a weapons expert who says
during this show she did a tactical
reload which means you're reloading
actually right before the action
thinking they're gonna need more
weaponry and you say wait a minute I
mean how could this be self-defense if
she reloaded so that wasn't true it was
not true and she didn't file other rape
claims that wasn't true that was on the
show and that was very the the detective
actually said against a number of men so
it sounds terrible going into this and
the fact this detective showed up
unannounced with cameras too is and the
defendant had no idea anything else oh
yeah she's pretty jumping to conclusions
over
well clearly T's erinmarie a must-see
episode Aaron thank you you can see
Aaron's full report reality kills
Saturday night on 48 hours it's at 10:00
9:00 central right here on CBS